[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce mardi 5 juin la
visite à versailles de jean michel
blanquer air à l'orangerie du château le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
rencontré des élèves de cm2 venus de
trappes bois d'arcy ou encore
rambouillet il leur a remis un recueil
des fables de la fontaine en présence de
l'illustrateur joann sfar qui signe les
dessins de l' ouvrage est dans cette
édition un témoignage poignant celui de
fabienne le close en 2016 sa vie bascule
lorsque juliette sa fille de 14 ans et
met fin à ses jours la rambo liten vient
de publier une lettre ouverte à son
enfant disparu elle nous l'avons
rencontré enfin c'est le premier salon
est dédié à la thématique à saint
quentin en yvelines le rendez-vous de
santé et bien-être se tient demain après
midi à la ferme du mas net à montigny le
bretonneux et lors de l'événement sera
signé le deuxième contrat local de santé
ils restent mobilisés contre la
construction d'une antenne relais à
noisy le roi hier une trentaine
d'habitants a participé à un
rassemblement citoyen devant la mairie
avant d'assister au conseil municipal
depuis plus d'un an ses riverains réunis
en comité se bat contre l'arrivée d'un
pylône de l'opérateur free une structure
de 34 mètres de haut qui doit être
érigée en zone boisée et à moins de 300
mètres des habitations
hier le maire a indiqué au comité avoir
écrit à free pour trouver des
alternatives à cette implantation à
l'opérateur s'y refuse et a saisi la
préfecture de région une réunion de
médiation à doit avoir lieu lundi
prochain la cigale et la fourmi le loup
et l'agneau ou encore le lièvre et la
tortue des fables bien connu dans le
cadre de l'opération un livre pour les
vacances huit cent mille élèves de cm2
ont reçu un exemplaire des fables de la
fontaine certains l'ont eu a dès cet
après midi à versailles des mains du
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer sur place camille
lambert
cela dit il faut que je me mange là
dessus au fond des forêts le loup
l'emportent
et puis le mange soit autre forme de
procès jean de la fontaine
la raison du plus fort est toujours la
meilleure c'est en tout cas ce que
montre le loup et l'agneau écrit en 1668
par jean de la fontaine à l'orangerie du
château de versailles 450 élèves de cm2
étaient réunis pour recevoir un
exemplaire de ces fables une initiative
menée par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
les fables de la fontaine ont quelque
chose d'éternel d'abord elle fonctionne
à tous les âges c'est à dire ça plaît
aux enfants aux adolescents aux adultes
et puis elles nous disent quelque chose
d'éternel puisqu'il ya toujours une âme
une morale des fables de la fontaine
et puis il ya une forme des fables de la
fontaine qui tout simplement nous mène
au beau c'est l'école du bien du vrai du
beau ce sont les trois notions qui sont
derrière tous les toutes les
transmissions de savoirs et toutes les
transmissions de valeur et donc la
fontaine fait partie de ces écrivains
qui d'une certaine façon rassemble tous
à un recueil enrichie par les dessins de
l'illustrateur johann sfar auteur du
chat du rabbin l'objectif donner goût à
la lecture l'idée c'est d'offrir un
livre illustré pour amener à mener une
peut-être une petite habitude qui est à
mon avis ni scolaire ni éducatif qui à
un moment de liberté où on s'approprie
un texte par les fables de la fontaine
ça me semble essentiel parce que ce sont
de petites chansons elles sont très
ironique elles ont un aspect oui un
petit peu provocant on est là ça peut
critiquer ou le pouvoir ou la famille ou
les proches en face et c'est fait pour
se moquer de ce qui nous entoure et voir
les travers des uns et des autres c'est
bien j'aime bien les dessins
faisant il est bien et les dessins et
son beau c'est encore une belle et sans
dommages ont bien lancé en 2010 est un
livre pour les vacances a permis cette
année à huit cent mille élèves de cm2 de
toute la france d'obtenir leurs ouvrages
une opération qui sera renouvelée tous
les ans avec un dessinateur différent
elles partagent déjà un même code postal
et une partie de la copropriété du
centre commercial parly 2 les villes du
chéné de rocquencourt ne feront
peut-être bientôt qu'une les deux maires
philippe brillault pour le chesnay que
vous voyez à l'image est celui de
rocquencourt et jean-françois peu
meurillon annoncé leur volonté de se
rassembler en une commune nouvelle
une fusion souhaitée avant le 1er
janvier 2019 pour des raisons
financières et face à des dotations de
l'état en baisse à vote d'un texte
identique pour acter le projet doit
avoir lieu lors de deux conseils
municipaux en simultané le 18 juin après
les accidents de la route le suicide est
la deuxième cause de mortalité chez les
15 24 ans le 2 janvier 2016 la vie de
cette habitante de rambouillet tourner
au drame
sa fille de 14 ans met fin à ses jours
deux ans plus tard fabienne le close
publie un ouvrage une lettre ouverte à
juliette sa benjamine disparu elle s'est
confiée à mélanie poquet témoignages
filmés par patrick jacques de dixmude
fabienne de klose nos jours bonjour
alors à juliette est sorti il ya un mois
comment déjà vous en est devenu al
écrire cet ouvrage
à force de lui écrire des grands mail ma
détresse d'avoir perdu juliette et
sachant qu'il avait vécu la même chose
j'ai commencé à faire des ateliers
d'écriture dès le mois d'avril est donc
dans six à des ateliers d'écriture me
suis rendu compte que ça me faisait du
bien d'écrire et de poser des mots
justes sur ce que je ressentais et
au fil du temps j'ai fait de plus en
plus d'ateliers diverses avec
différentes personnes
et voilà comment tu arrives à l'idée
d'écrire à 7,7 et naturel chose et vous
avez choisi de l'adresser à juliette
voulu parler tout le temps mais qui
était-elle juliette juliette c'était une
petite fille très mignon je trouve nager
sa maman un peu mystérieuse malgré tout
le monde qui au fil du temps séparé un
peu sa vie de famille où tout se passe
est vraiment très bien et est une
famille vraiment soudée vous avez
beaucoup de choses ensemble
le week-end de la cohérence et juliette
était une passionnée et passionné de
piano de gymnastique c'est d'aviation
elle voulait faire pilotes de ligne et
est donc où est donc l séparé vraiment
c'est sous les lieux avec ses amis de
l'école de ce qu'ont fait pas beaucoup
sur ce qui se passait et je pense que
ses amis ne connaissent pas juliette
comme on la connaît effet de faire ça
juliette était un enfant à haut
potentiel je dis dans mon livre et cette
fois là sont vraiment différents enfin
certains s'il peut être pas tous
beaucoup plus sensibles beaucoup plus
têtu à la recherche de réponses et qui l
avait beaucoup de peur d'eux
de phobie de peur de la mort ça se prend
vraiment constante et nous recherche du
sens de la vie qui a été assez présent
en fait pour alain son suicide est une
surprise pour vous c'est ce qu'on
ressent dans les premières pages de
votre ouvrage d'écrire un tel livre
c'est aussi pour alerter et informer ce
ne soit plus un tabou oui oui oui mais
ça a été une complète surprise brévent
attiré parce qu'on ne s'y attendait pas
du tout on en venait de rentrer de
vacances au mois d'août on était encore
ce n'était bien enfin moment on a fêté
ses 14 ans et avec des bronzes vraiment
pas de signe d' alerte après la
commencer l'année en disant je vais
absolument prendre des cours de maths
particulier pour pour réussir match et
tout pour faire un pilote de ligne et
elle se projetaient est vraiment elle
était rentrée en seconde avec des amis
enfin il n'a pas vraiment une vie
sociale d'après elle était assez
populaire juliette est donc évidemment
quand quand elle fait ça on est
complètement atterrée et pour la écrire
pour déjà pour parler du tabou du
suicide parce que c'est vraiment on a
l'impression que si on lit un livre sur
celui-ci devait tout on va se suicider
que c'est c'est un tel tabou même de nos
jours
et pourtant c'est la deuxième cause de
mortalité chez les jeunes
monsieur side donc je pense que j'espère
que si les jeunes le 10 de mon livre
enfin déjà j'ai eu des retours de jeunes
qui m'ont dit mais on se rend compte de
ce que ça laisse après parce qu'ils font
passer un peu de suicide
donc il se rend compte de vraiment delà
de la famille qui laisse après derrière
de la réalité du suicide dont 7
c'est justement dans le voir vous ne
cachez jamais votre douleur non aux
souffrances et l'impact que ça va sur
votre époux et vous de vos deux autres
filles je n'en pense que si on témoigne
il faut pas cacher parce que si on
commença à cacher a pas dire des choses
parce que il faut pas parce que après
c'est plus un témoignage c'est plus
juste
moi je voulais que ça soit vraiment
juste ça ressemble presque à un journal
intime
oui tout est très précis vous avez tout
gras tout gardé dans votre mémoire
depuis le 1er janvier même la veille 2
oui je suis cette année il est oui bah
j'ai tout j'ai écrit j'ai repris des
mails que j'avais écrit un patrick et en
modernisant parce que je mets écrivait
quotidiennement
donc là oui je vais bien j'ai pu
retrouver puis j'ai crevé au 6e rang
cahier je pense que j'ai commencé à
écrire parce que je redis justement vu
les mecs je l'avais envoyé le 16 janvier
j'ai commencé à écrire à lui dire je
vais vous avez crise et le livre sur une
semaine
j'ai eu mal je vais essayer de faire
pareil vous terminez avec une phrase
s'il te plaît juliette fais moi un signe
on est en octobre 2017 quand vous
décrivez aujourd'hui est ce que vous
attendez toujours vous avez passé un
nouveau cap
peut-être avec la sortie de l'ouvragé
j'attends tout cet ouvrage me portent
beaucoup en fait ça ça m'aide
oui ça me porte en fait c'est le mot
juste et j'attends toujours un signe de
julia toi j'attends j'aimerais venir
après tout me dit mais le fait que tu
écris c'est un signe
il ya plein de choses comme ça après je
dis bah le fait pourquoi j'ai écrit à
ppda
le 4 janvier deux joueurs deux jours
après c'est quand j'ai réfléchi je me
sers impressionnant pourquoi pourquoi je
l'écris pourquoi ça mais revenir la tête
il avait écrit sur solène et j'ai pas de
réponse alors est ce que ce sont des
signes je sais pas merci fabien ne close
alors je vous en prie à juliette est
publié chez flammarion depuis le 9 mai
les équipes de sodexo mobilisés contre
la faim dans le monde
à guyancourt 750 personnes ont participé
au servathon stop hunger une opération
de collecte alimentaire qui vient de se
clôturer
elle est salariée ont réalisé une chaîne
humaine au total 5 tonnes de produits
récoltés c'est une demi-tonne de plus
par rapport à l'année dernière et ces
denrées vont au profit des restos du
coeur propos recueillis par manon
varaldo et clémence tergnier alors
l'idée du servathon c'est de collecter
les six produits dans les restos ont le
plus besoin à savoir les conserves de
fruits de légumes de poissons mais aussi
les féculents le lait et les produits
pour bébés
et tout ça ça s'organise sur toute la
france donc aujourd'hui on a collecté 5
tonnes pour les restos 5 tonnes en laye
c'est un peu plus d'une demi tonne de
plus que l'année dernière donc on est
vraiment fiers de cette de cette belle
performance et c'est venu mobiliser les
tous les collaborateurs qui sont
présents ici et sur les 1000 qui sont là
il y en a sept cent cinquante qui ont
fait au moins un don alors que le joli
mois de leroy vient de se terminer focus
à présent sur une entreprise
saint-quentinoise qui profite à des
fonds européens pour se développer des
subventions qui peuvent aller de
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros à
plusieurs millions reportage d'aurélie
rond et nicolas kirillovitch
favoriser l'émergence et le
développement des entreprises
saint-quentinoise
voilà l'ambition du ski cube créé il ya
un peu plus d'un an
l'incubateur située à guyancourt a
permis en 2010 est la concrétisation de
270 création et reprise d'entreprise
un accompagnement possible grâce
notamment aux fonds européens
le ski cub a bénéficié d'une subvention
de 333 1659 euros profité de l'europe
pour se développer
c'est aussi le cas de l'entreprise
émules sarr basée à montigny le
bretonneux elle est spécialisée dans la
conception d'ingrédients innovant sous
forme d'émulsion un projet phare dans le
domaine de la nutrition clinique que
nous souhaitions développer par
nous-mêmes mais avec un manque de moyens
nous a donné l'idée et l'envié d'aller
chercher des fonds européens pour
pouvoir justement nous aider à financer
le développement l'industrialisation et
la commercialisation de de ce projet en
propre avec aime ça alors on a démarré
le projet
en 2015 e
on a commencé à monter le monter le
dossier et obtenu donc la réponse et les
fonds en 2007 ont commencé réellement le
travailler sur le projet en 2016 est
donc maintenant jusqu'en jusqu'en 2019
avec une enveloppe d'un peu plus d'1 7
million d'euros pour faire une demande
de fonds européens certaines entreprises
se tourna vers des sociétés de conseil à
magny les hameaux cap industrie fait
partie du cluster gennari ce groupe
parmi ses activités le montage de
dossiers de financement européen
ce que l'on fait c'est qu'on va
rechercher des projets enfin ou des
entités qui sont à la recherche de fonds
à la fois publics mais aussi privés et
donc on va mettre en adéquation enfin
voilà leur ferme leur permettre de
gagner un peu de temps et donc nous on
est là juste pour apporter la valeur
ajoutée c'est-à-dire corrigé les
dossiers les mettre en oeuvre
voilà s'assurer qu'ils sont bien monter
quand des entreprises qui parfois se
découragent face à la complexité des
dossiers et pourtant elles ont tout à y
gagner
justement les français sont un peu mal
placé là dessus
on est peu demandeur de ne faut pas les
fonds c'est pas une perte de temps parce
qu'on peut s'en servir pour d'autres
d'autres recherches de financement donc
non c'est pas difficile ça demande du
temps sa demande de l'investissement sa
demande
de 10 mètres un peu de passion mais
voilà c'est le métier des entrepreneurs
je crois pour la période 2014 2020 la
région ile de france dispose d'une
enveloppe de 540 millions d'euros de
fonds européens
elle vient tout juste de lancer un appel
à projets autour des programmes agrio
d'un c'est le premier salon du genre à
saint quentin en yvelines le rendez vous
santé et bien-être et au programme
demain c'est à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux de 13h à 18h et
des ateliers rencontres et animations
sont au menu on en parle tout de suite
avec deux invités catherine chevalier
bonsoir non ça vous est la responsable
de lits ps l'institut de promotion de la
santé de saint quentin en yvelines qui
organise donc cet événement avec nos
également dominique 80 bonsoir soit
conseillère communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines vous êtes délégué à
l'action sociale et à la santé alors
c'est le premier rendez vous du genre je
le disais pourquoi fallait-il pour
l'agglomération proposer cet événement
comment dire est que le contrat local de
santé le premier s'est terminée donc en
2010 est donc en décembre donc bien
entendu c'était le premier dans les
yvelines aussi est le premier surtout
l'agglomération a tout fait pour que ce
soit le premier aussi au sein de
l'ile-de-france donc ça c'est quand même
un point à noter je pense qu'on peut en
être fier donc bien entendu il fallait
pas en rester là
nous avons bien entendu avec catherine
et puis toute l'équipe de lee ps et et
nos partenaires bien sûr voulu signer un
nouveau contrat local de santé et donc
qui va voir le jour là parce qu'il ya
une situation d'urgence on sent tout à
fait à compter de demain le premier
contrat nous avions trois partenaires là
nous avons neuf partenaires donc les 3
l'écriture des yvelines bien d'autres
partenaires en est à noter aussi les
trois hôpitaux là qui nous entoure donc
je vais nommer mme migneault la verrière
est également comment dirais-je plaisir
donc ses calmes et il ya aussi
université de saint quentin également
alors c'est un contrat qui courra
jusqu'à la période 2018 2024 c'est ce
que ça permet concrètes
concrètement pardon un contrat local de
santé ça permet de haut niveau de nos
douze communes parce qu'en fin de compte
ça va concerner nos communes donc on
peut innover en santé on peut on a une
cartographie vraiment très très pointue
de nos communes avec les besoins de
chacun donc ça nous permet aussi de voir
un petit peu ce qui se passe sur toutes
ces communes de répondre à certaines
problématiques que rencontrent ça va
nous permettre aussi de travailler avec
ses partenaires de mettre plein de
choses encore en commun qu'on n'avait
pas eu le temps de mettre jusqu'à
présent parce que le premier contrat
local en avait on avait été ambitieux
très ambitieux et en fin de compte on
s'est aperçu qu'il fallait faire moins
mais peut-être un peu mais aller plus
dans le détail c'est pour ça que pour le
premier contrat nous avions cinq axes et
là nous avons tous globalisé sur trois
axes et donc ça sera signé demain à
l'occasion de ce salon santé et
bien-être
revenons-en justement au programme de ce
salon on pourra catherine chevalier
trouvaient sur place tout un réseau de
professionnels du secteur sur la santé
le bien-être
oui tout à fait en fait on va être
autour d'eux des thématiques et
novations des thématiques bien-être des
thématiques prévention et sport santé
également donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
décliner le document cls en fait de
manière concrète et attractive avec il y
aura des ateliers qui sont vraiment tout
public c'est gratuit c'est ouvert à tous
il y aura aussi des conférences des mini
conférences y aura des spectacles sans
oublier aussi des exposants et l'idée en
fait c'est de pouvoir faire un événement
ouvert à tous pour bien faire connaître
aussi la politique de santé et
l'institut de promotion de la santé pour
tous parce qu'on connaît bien l'y ps
quand on est un professionnel
mais quand on est un habitant c'est
quand on a
besoin d'aller vers les partenaires
qu'on héberge attrape convient vers l'ip
est donc l'idée c'est de donner de la
visibilité à la politique de santé de
l'agglomération alors 1500 mètres carrés
d'espacé demain sur place une
quarantaine de stands vous avez évoqué
la thématique sport santé c'est l'une
des quatre thématiques qui seront
proposées demain
alors depuis quelques mois et
expérimenté à saint quentin en yvelines
la prescription de sport sur ordonnance
c'est ça oui c'est vraiment les prémices
bon il ya il yad'autres comment
dirais-je ça c'est fait aussi sur
strasbourg ça ça se plaît je crois se
pose pour sur ordonnance mais comment
dirais-je pour ça se développe mais bon
là normalement c'est c'est vraiment nous
sommes vraiment prémices donc là on peut
on n'a pas un recul suffisamment grand
encore à l'heure actuelle pour dire
éventuellement ce que ça peut nous
apporter mais moi j'y crois beaucoup en
innovation parce que ça je pense aussi
que dans notre secteur de nos douze
communes on a besoin de ce sport parce
qu'on s'aperçoit quand même qu'on a
quand même beaucoup de maladies
cardiovasculaires donc par ce biais là
peut-être que ça pourrait amener un plus
pour te pour pour toutes ces personnes
qui souffrent de cela et puis ce qu'on
pourrait dire aussi en a quand même sur
des particularités de maladies
chroniques sur nos douze communes on a
de l'asthme
on est d'ailleurs qui est vraiment un
peu plus en grandeur que la moyenne de
tous les yvelines on a aussi comment
dirais-je de ce que je disais tout à
l'heure les maladies cardiovasculaires
et on a aussi des cancers un peu plus
élevé que dans les autres communes du
département
et voilà ce qu'on peut dire mais en fin
de compte je pense aussi que c'est un
regroupement de tout cela qu'on veut
mettre au jour parce que je pense comme
disait catherine tout à leur lit ps
n'est pas connu peut-être un peu plus
pour les gens de trappes mais comment
dirais-je les douze communes ne
connaissaient pas spécialement
comment dirais-je du ps et c'est vrai
que par nos actions en commun depuis à
peu près deux ou trois ans nous avons
rencontré avec catherine tous les
partenaires toutes les communes et ça
c'est comme un bien-être de comment
dirais-je qu'on a ressenti une écoute
aussi des partenaires parce que nous
avons des référents élus et de santé sur
toutes les communes et donc ça nous
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui nous
portent vraiment très fort pour
continuer et toujours à lille avant
envers les communes parce que je pense
que c'est là où en fin de compte on peut
voir le plus mal être des gens est qu'on
puisse nous entendre agglo et apporter
notre contribution et on l'a dit un
programme très varié et demain il y aura
de la conférences des animations des
ateliers je vous invite d'ailleurs à
consulter le lien qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran pour retrouver tout le
programme
merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous
catherine chevalier responsable de lits
ps et l'institut de promotion de la
santé publique de saint quentin en
yvelines qui organise donc cet événement
et merci à dominique catelin conseillère
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines est déléguée à l'action sociale
et à la santé merci d'avoir été avec
nous retour en arrière à présent ce
samedi le parvis de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines s'est transformé en
un petit vélodrome à l'occasion de la
fête nationale du vélo est les curieux
ont pu se renseigner sur l'histoire du
cyclisme et tester différents types de
vélos
reportage en roue libre de michael et
l'hydro alors la façon d'apprendre à
faire du vélo et courir les notions et
qui voyage dans le passé sur le parvis
de la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
à l'occasion de la fête nationale du
vélo des bicyclettes venue d'un autre
temps rouler sur le bitume ce samedi 2
juin
on retrouve cet esprit cet esprit un peu
pionniers cet esprit un peu inventif un
peu délirant même peut-être pour
certains puisque c'est vrai que la forme
de certains vélos sont assez atypiques
et on a pu le remarquer déjà la tête de
certaines personnes en disait en disait
long sur leur leur étonnement et leur
surprise de voir des vélos qui qui
roulent encore malgré certains qui ont
près de qom cela par exemple 200 ans
presque donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
impressionnant sur l'après midi une
vingtaine de têtes brûlées se sont
testés sur le parcours le geste fut
parfois hésitant et l' usage des pieds
recommander certains novices ont même
tenté de s'associer d'autres se sont
même des
courage avant de monter sur la scène et
on préfère rester dans la zone
spectateurs
c'est un mois pas prendre je pourrais
pas quelques pilotes au contraire n'ont
pas eu froid aux yeux au moment de se
lancer
au rayon d'action plus difficiles que
d'autres mais après moi je sais que j'ai
toujours fait du sport j'ai fait du surf
donc bon niveau d'équilibré pas trop de
soucis l'activité très ludique elle
mélange les générations et je ne
connaissais pas du tout ce type de vélo
dont je suis très contente de cette
découverte et de l'accompagnement qui
est fait par les sympathiques animateurs
les participants pourront maintenant se
tester avec des vélos moderne sur les
400 km de pistes cyclables de saint
quentin en yvelines elle dimanche il
s'était à 108 personnes à vélo justement
à se rassembler devant la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines venu de guyancourt
d'elancourt ou encore de plaisir ces
cyclistes se sont retrouvés pour la
convergence francilienne une cyclo
balade manif'estives ouverte à tous des
cortèges partis d'une centaine de villes
de la région se sont dirigés vers paris
le rendez vous était fixé place de la
bastille pour une parade finale suivie
d'un pique nique géant et localement
c'est le groupe
mdb vélo sky qui a organisé l
encadrement tout au long du week-end la
ville de guyancourt organisé son
traditionnel tournoi de la balle dehors
c'est du tennis de table et plus de 400
points gist se sont affrontés au gymnase
des droits de l'homme parmi eux neuf
joueurs en situation de handicap camille
lambert et michael et demi d'euros
c'était une grande première pour le
tournoi de label d'or des yvelines des
joueurs handisport ont intégré la
compétition départementale cette année
au total trois joueurs en fauteuil et
six joueurs de boue se sont inscrits
auprès des organisateurs
on a créé dont deux tableaux on a créé
un tableau fauteuil ce qu'on appelle un
tableau a signé un tableau de glee on
n'a pas l'habitude de les voir comme ça
dans une épreuve départementale donc
c'est ça qui est sympa c'est montrer un
petit peu à tout le monde ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire
et puis de voir que finalement c'est pas
si facile de jouer contre eux parce que
ils ont aidé d'autres méthodes de jeu
et ils savent aussi embêtée leurs
adversaires pour remporter des victoires
ce dimanche 3 juin à guyancourt certains
pongistes sont passés d'un plusieurs
mois d'entraînement c'est le cas de
sandrine copains du club de wazin le
bretonneux
elle jouait ce test au tennis de table
depuis un an j'en ai fait un petit peu
en valide donc de me retrouver en
fauteuil puisque maintenant je suis
handicapé et devoir trouver le geste est
plus le même geste donc c'est beaucoup
il faut oublier tout ce que je savais
avant quoi donc c'est compliqué une fois
le geste maîtriser place à la stratégie
yorick hadjal joueurs de l'équipe de
france à son plan de bataille
le ping pong fauteuil est beaucoup plus
tactique et c'est plus technique le tout
on valide le placement de mal à être
différent on va être lésé sur certaines
balles donc il faut vraiment
stratégiquement réfléchir à tous c'est
un vrai jeu ça devient un vrai jeu
d'échecs en fait c'est vrai qu'elle est
les zones sont très gênante pour nous en
fauteuil donc on va chercher à alléger
notre adversaire pour lui faire un coupé
sur le coup et c'est grave
vu le succès rencontré cette année les
neuf pour gist handisport sont déjà
prêts à resservir l'année prochaine sur
le tournoi de la balle tort des yvelines
et puis à neuf jours du début de la
coupe du monde de football emmanuel
macron a fait un saut dont les yvelines
le président de la république est venu à
clairefontaine salué les 23 joueurs de
l'équipe de france sélectionnés pour le
mondial ainsi que le staff technique
elle nous serons d'ailleurs demain
mercredi en direct du centre
d'entraînement pour vivre le dernier
entraînement des bleus ouvert au public
avant le grand départ pour la russie
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi très bonne soirée est sur
tv 78
[Musique]